and it's not like you know i could go
and get a job
waiting tables
because a i was right still recognizable
b my ego
so you know i was like detailing cars
with my cousin
to try to make a try to make a living at
certain things and it's not not that i'm
afraid of work because i love working i
love to work with my hands i love to i
love manual labor um
and i
i
i i really do um but the ego it was the
ego really it wasn't it was the ego it
was the ego as i was like a [ __ ] dude
i can't even walk into a mall without
people recognizing me but i i'm i'm
fighting to get a job like what am i
going to do what did you just yeah
it was a bad position to be in
and how long did it take you before you
started making money again and you were
all right
uh well the show wrapped in 94 when we
did the college years and i think 96 is
when i started working again i got a i
got a tv movie for nbc of all places
because we were always on nbc and i got
a nbc movie that i auditioned for um it
wasn't an offer and then uh after that
things started happening again but
i don't know man you know it's like i
i think that
everything is
everything is
dispensable in a way you know
nothing is
in my eyes forever
and i just want to make sure that i
appreciate everything that i have in my
life and
not take it for granted you know my
marriage my kids
my health yeah um you know there's a
point in your life where you just
realize holy [ __ ] it's all limited right
like it's
it's it's it's not it's it's not we're
not gonna be here forever
yeah that's for sure i think that's true
the older you get you start to think
about
wow we're all expendable we're all going
to the same place how many years do i
actually have left and what do i really
love what do i really want to who do i
really want to spend my time with in
these how however many years you have
you start to think more about those
things
yeah i when i when i was going through
um the divorce my my uh
therapist at the time um
he basically said uh you know a lot of
people think life is short he goes but
it's not it's long life is long and i
was 36 when i when i was going through
this and he said you've only been living
your life for about 18 years you know
when you when you be when you turned 18
you became an adult you started living
your life because you have another 50
plus years ahead of you
that are all yours you can make
you can it's your decisions
uh and he says so
think about that like
the amount of time it took me to get to
36 and that felt like a lifetime and it
goes but you you haven't even
you have
50 years of that left yeah